President Trump is spending Thanksgiving
day at his mar-a-lago Resort in Florida
this morning he tweeted Happy
Thanksgiving your country is starting to
do really well jobs coming back highest
stock market ever the president plans to
meet congressional leaders next week to
discuss a busy agenda for the end of the
year
Errol Barnett is in West Palm Beach
traveling with the president Erol good
morning good morning after Thanksgiving
president Trump will have to deal with
tax reform avoiding a government
shutdown and the controversial Alabama
Senate race today he calls members of
the military to thank them for their
service
but yesterday President Trump was more
combative than thankful with a laundry
list of big ticket items waiting for him
in Washington President Trump spent the
first day of his Thanksgiving vacation
tending to more trivial matters like his
war of words with levar Bal the father
of a UCLA basketball player detained in
China for shoplifting President Trump
said in a tweet it wasn't the US
government or father lavars so-called
people on the ground in China that got
his son out it was me he went on to say
ball is a poor man's version of Don King
without the hair and called him an
ungrateful fool bull downplayed the
president's Twitter tirade yesterday and
still refuses to thank mr. Trump his son
Lee Angelou and to UCLA teammates were
detained in China earlier this month for
shoplifting at the time President Trump
was making a state visit to Beijing and
spoke with Chinese President gee about
the players predicament
shortly after Chinese authorities
released them upon their return to the
States
UCLA basketball suspended all three
indefinitely
the trio held a press conference to
apologise for their actions I'd also
like to thank President Trump in the
United States government the president
also renewed another old battle
yesterday he took aim at the NFL yet
again for considering keeping players
inside the locker room during the
national anthem which he believes to be
almost as bad as kneeling now what's
notable is who president
Trump has chosen to defend Republican
senator Roy Moore who faces multiple
allegations of sexual misconduct
now before heading on this vacation mr.
Trump said people should also pay
attention to Moore's denials as well
bianna aryl Thanks